-Welcome, everybody.
Welcome, welcome, welcome.
to "The Tonight Show"!
You're here!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Than you for watching at home.
I want to wish everyone
a very happy Thanksgiving.
Happy Thanksgiving, everyone.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Happy Thanksgiving.
By now, your pants have
completed their journey from on
to unbuttoned
to "Who needs pants?"
So congratulations.
Please get comfortable.
Relax.
You just did all the dishes.
Or you stood around
pretending to be busy
to avoid doing the dishes,
whatever you did.
And, actually, I'd like to make
a quick public-service
announcement, if I could.
If you're still at someone's
house watching me right now,
everyone wants you to go home.
[ Laughter ]
Goodbye.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Go.
It's time.
Of course, Thanksgiving was
a little different this year.
Your cousin, who was super
into crypto last Thanksgiving,
not so chatty anymore, right?
[ Laughter ]
It's a big night.
Not only is it Thanksgiving,
but we're coming to you
after tonight's game
between the Minnesota Vikings
and the New England Patriots.
The Patriots playing
on Thanksgiving makes sense
because most people started
the day looking like this.
And then after all
the eating and stress,
they end up looking like this.
And, uh...
[ Laughter ]
Some relatives
wanted to watch football,
others wanted to watch
the World Cup,
while your one creepy nephew
wanted everyone
to watch "Dahmer."
And you go, "No."
Well, get this. I read that
because of inflation,
the cost of this year's
Thanksgiving dinner
was up about 20%.
It was tough,
especially if you love
basting your turkey
with premium gasoline.
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, Turkey was nearly
75% more expensive.
Yeah. Let's just say
if you ate a turducken,
the "tur" might've been turtle.
[ Laughter ]
I actually saw that,
due to rising prices of turkey
and other meats, a lot of people
served plant-based alternatives.
-Ooh.
[ Audience groans ]
So if you want to know
why Arby's and Taco Bell
are open on Thanksgiving,
that's why.
[ Laughter ]
But it's not just inflation.
Turkeys were also
harder to come by
'cause of a bird-flu outbreak.
Everything else going around.
Just to be safe, people also
serve masked potatoes.
[ Laughter ]
You guys see -- Masked.
[ Rimshot ]
-Masked.
-Masked -- thank you.
Masked potatoes.
-M-A-S-K -- masked.
-That's a joke for everybody.
-Not mashed.
-No, no.
-Masked.
-Did you see this, Higgins?
Frank's RedHot just released
an injector
to help you get hot sauce
into your turkey this year.
Look at this thing.
-Oh.
It's a great way
to spice up your turkey.
And if you mix
in a little Pfizer,
even better way to get
your uncle vaccinated.
[ Laughter ]
"Just have some more turkey.
White meat or dark --
Breast?"
[ Applause ]
This is wild.
I saw a survey that said
this Thanksgiving,
a third of Americans serve food
infused with cannabis.
[ Scattered cheers ]
Yep, weed
and operating a deep-fryer --
what could possibly go wrong?
[ Laughter ]
'Course, weed's always been
a part of Thanksgiving.
The Pilgrims were so stoned,
they put buckles on their hats.
I mean, come on.
[ Laughter ]
Also, it's probably
not the best day to be high.
It's like, "Dude,
I swear I saw a 50-foot
Pillsbury Doughboy
floating down Sixth Avenue."
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, another poll said
that on Thanksgiving,
36% of Americans admit
to drinking more than usual.
You know you drank too much
when there's enough
empty wine boxes to build
a fort, don't you think?
[ Laughter ]
But all jokes aside, we have
so much to be thankful for.
We live in the greatest
nation on Earth.
We're --
[ Cheers and applause ]
We're making it
through a pandemic.
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And no matter
what channel you watch,
there's a commercial
featuring Shaq.
You know what I'm saying?
[ Cheers and applause ]
There's so much to be
grateful for these days.
I think we should take a moment
and go around
and say what we're thankful for.
I will start.
I am thankful for my family,
my friends, and this video.
-Ugh!
Oh, my gosh.
Ugh!
What do I do?
[ Burps ]
[ Laughter ]
-What about you?
What about you, Higgins?
-Well, I'm thankful
for my kids and my wife
and this video.
-[ Inhales, coughs ]
[ Laughter ]
-Man
Okay.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
That's interesting. Yeah.
What about you, Tariq?
-Well, I'm thankful
for my bandmates, my fans...
-Yeah.
-...and this video.
-I got these new boots.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-And finally, Quest,
what about you?
-I'm thankful for my relatives,
my friends, and this video.
-Bye!
-[ Screaming ]
[ Laughter ]
-[Bleep] [bleep]
-What?
What?!
[ Applause ]
It's important to give thanks.
Hey, this is fun.
Today, the 96th Annual
Macy's Thanksgiving Day Parade
aired on NBC.
96.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I was there. We were there.
The Roots and I
were at the -- at the parade.
I was honored to be performing
at the parade,
although it was tough
when kids were shouting,
"Jimmy, we loved your balloon!"
and I had to tell them,
"I don't have a balloon.
That's just my head."
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-The parade was great, although,
sadly, after a gust of wind,
the Chase
from "Paw Patrol" balloon
was neutered
by the Empire State Building.
[ Laughter ]
Terrible.
It's unfortunate.
That's right.
The parade had 16 balloons,
28 floats, 12 marching bands,
and get this,
more than 700 clowns.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
But it got weird
when Macy's said...
"We didn't hire any clowns."
-♪ Ring around the rosie ♪
♪ Pocket full of posies ♪
♪ Ashes -- ♪
-Thank you.
Of course, Thanksgiving marks
the official start
of the holiday shopping season,
but I heard that, this year,
Walmart, Target, and Best Buy
were all closed for the day.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's right.
They told their employees,
"Take the day off.
We don't want to see you here
until 12:01 a.m.
Okay, good."
[ Laughter ]
And, finally,
according to a new survey,
a decent night of sleep
is at the top of most
Americans' holiday wish list.
So if you made it
through my monologue,
you're getting sleepy.
You're getting sleepy.
But you're gonna
want to stick around
because Jerry Seinfeld is here
tonight!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Jerry Seinfeld!
[ Cheers and applause
continues ]
Adam Devine is on the show
this evening!
And we got a performance
from Bruce Springsteen tonight!
We have a great show.
Let's go write some
thank-you notes.
Come on, everybody.
-♪ I'm down for one more
turkey sandwich ♪
♪ I'm holding out for one more
-Oh, my goodness.
Happy Thanksgiving, everybody.
I hope everyone had a great day.
Today is just about over,
and I, uh -- I just thought
I'd take a look
at my Thanksgiving Bingo card.
-Oh.
-Might as well.
Yeah, I already had dinner.
Let's see how I did here.
Okay, first up,
in this square, we have...
Yep.
[ Laughter ]
"Devon?
Oh, it's Taran."
This next square says...
Ah!
A lot of summer soaps.
Some are real.
Who knows?
So I got -- I'm two for two
on that one.
-Two for two, dude.
-Yeah.
Let's see this next square here.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Mid.
-Wow.
-Didn't happen to me.
Let's take a look
at this next one here.
[ Laughter ]
"Hey, dude."
-"Hey, man."
-"What are we eatin', man?"
-"Big turkey, dude."
-"You got any Funyuns, dude?
All right."
Uh...
[ Laughter ]
That didn't happen to me.
Oh, well,
here's the free space --
Okay, well, that's --
Everyone gets that one.
Everyone gets that one,
of course.
The next square says...
-Oh.
-Not this year.
Not this year, thankfully.
-Last year.
-Yeah, last year.
That's a different story.
How about this one?
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-"What do you know?
What do you know?"
That didn't happen to me.
How about this one here?
Yeah, actually did happen to me.
I'll take that one.
Uh, and finally...
Oh, that's --
Hey, I got Bingo!
-Yeah!
-I got Thanksgiving Bingo!
All right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Guys, today is a day
all about giving thanks,
so why not a better day
to write out my weekly
Thank You Notes right now?
You guys mind?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, I'd love to.
James, can I get some
Thank You Note writing music,
please?
♪♪
-Wow.
Thankful.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Thank you,
Thanksgiving leftovers,
for leading to an epic game
of Fridge Tetris.
[ Laughs ]
[ Applause ]
♪♪
Thank you,
canned cranberry sauce,
for being the only thing
that keeps its shape
after Thanksgiving.
Yeah. Can't mess with that.
I like --
I like a good dessert
to have -- that has abs.
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
♪♪
-Thank you, World Cup trophy.
-Ooh.
-Because everyone knows
the first rule of soccer
is hold the ball with two hands.
[ Laughter ]
Wait. What?
-What?
[ Applause ]
♪♪
-Thank you, peeling potatoes,
for either being a sign
that you're helping Mom or did
something wrong in boot camp.
[ Applause ]
"Beetle Bailey!"
-"Get over here!"
♪♪
-Thank you, Thanksgiving,
for being that special day
when your family is either upset
you're not married
or upset about
who you did marry.
[ Laughs ]
[ Applause ]
"He's a loozah!"
♪♪
Thank you,
airport X-ray machine,
for letting me work off
Thanksgiving
by doing one very slow
jumping jack.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
♪♪
Thank you, family photos,
for letting me remember
exactly what mood each family
member was in at the time.
There you have it, everybody.
Those are our Thank You Notes.
We'll be right back.